now the legal world can seem pretty set
in its ways a labyrinth of partnerships
self-employed barristers and decades-old
ownership arrangements one firm of
solicitors Rosenblatt hopes to challenge
that with a new approach and it shares
began trading on the alternative
investment market today
well thirty years ago Nicola Fulton was
its first client and now she's the chief
executive she used to run the motor
racing circuit Brands Hatch and was the
youngest ever winner of the Verve
Clicquot businesswoman the year old
she's with me Nana clear very good
evening to you so why have you come to
market so we wanted to raise funds to
have our own in-house litigation fund
the ability to have skin in the game
that's been around for about a decade
now more and more clients are used to it
and they expect law firms to be able to
participate in that and also to raise
funds for acquisition I think the legal
sector is facing considerable challenges
in the years ahead there's going to be a
considerable consolidation it's a very
fragmented market and Rosenblatt wants
to take advantage of that it's what's
wrong with the old partnership model
winner
I think the lockstep equity partner
model is not fit for purpose in the
current time I know dramatic a dramatic
view I think it's it served its purpose
I think it breeds discontent
disenfranchisement of those that are
stuck in the system beneath and I think
yes dead man's shoes bed blocking caller
what you will and I think that the
opportunity of having corporate paper
shares in an entity that can then pass
value to your staff is a better way of
incentivizing motivating and retaining
your talent
so anyone you're recruiting them
presumably from that one you will be
offering them shares and the business
that are tradable yes absolutely and
obviously that is a key part of the
reason for coming to market when it is
seven years since we have this big
shake-up in the legal industry you know
the onset of Tesco laws people called at
the time you're only the fourth law firm
to YPO since then hasn't caught on in
the way that we thought it would has it
well no because nothing in law happens
quickly and and indeed in that time
those licenses that have been issued to
firms that are either commercially
managed or commercially owned has
predominantly been to the accountancy
actually have gone into the legal sector
or when you've wanted to put the finance
director on on your executive it hasn't
been used as Ian Rosenblatt has to bring
in commercial management like me I'm the
first commercial CEO non-legal see over
law firm in this country that's amazing
why sure you had conservative the
industry absolutely yes but I mean if we
take Slater and Gordon which was the
first-ever law firm lest Australian firm
in that didn't exactly end well for
investors did it and I think that proves
my point
it wasn't commercially managed and there
are like there are in every businesses
there are key risks that need to be
managed and Slater and Gordon I won't
bore you with the reasons but they had a
specific area they did not manage
successfully and it was their undoing
and it is something that is faces all
legal firms there are aspects of your
business that you need to manage in a
fairly commercial hard-nosed way so what
do you bring to the party that a
traditional lawyer CEO couldn't bring to
it well I think there's a couple of
things the first is that it to suggest
that you can be a lawyer all of your
life we voted in as Managing Partner and
do two week training course at Harvard
and you know I had to run a business
sort of somewhat Hutt's and then and
then someone like myself who's had 30
years business experience I don't think
that can be matched in a in a sort of
two week course I think the second thing
is that I am ultimately a client I am
poacher turned gamekeeper and I look at
the business through a client's eyes and
put the client first and that for me is
a really important point about the say
it's the same when I went to Brands
Hatch it was a very inward looking
business very focused on the product law
is the same and I think that needs to
change and the focus needs to be on the
client but isn't there a danger that
doing the right thing by shareholders
may compromise your ability to do the
right thing by clients I mean the two
may not necessarily be aligned and I
think that's another very important way
in which we've structured the business
legal management is separated from
commercial management and therefore the
lawyers relationship with the client
remains privileged and sacrosanct and
the decisions regarding the day-to-day
commercial running the business are left
with me and my team who do not engage in
any aspects of the legal practice how do
you assess the riskiness rather wise of
shares in
business like this I mean essentially
it's a bet on the individuals the
company's best assets walk in and out
the door every day don't there's been
like an advertising company in that
sense I guess is it well again that's
been said to me a lot unsurprisingly I
think that people are the most important
part of just about every business I know
and I have been involved with and my job
as the CEO is to build the brand behind
the individuals and to institutionalize
and create that relationship with the
clients and again having been a client
it is a fallacy to think that clients
are buying people and not the brand